andrew bittner
good to see you it's good to be here
thank you for having me
thanks so much for coming on the show
been a fan
quietly and not so quietly and
excited to actually have made my way out
here and and be
in la and be in the same space it's
wonderful
honored by that and likewise
have been a massive fan and
people around the planet are
they know deep in their hearts that
the transition to clean energy
infrastructures
is at the core it's
at nearly this equivalent level
of consciousness like we need
to both handle this inner kingdom
of our awareness and also handle this
exterior kingdom
of the planet and making it renewable
sustainable
prosperous abundant people know it
that's at the key it's kind of fun to be
able to be in the renewable space right
now because it is so connected
to all of the other uh awakenings that
seem to be happening and as people are
starting to advance and
and see the value in long-term type of
decision making and sustainability and
we're certainly riding that wave uh was
kind of an uphill battle
originally when we started into this
field and now
the winds are blowing in the right
direction and we couldn't be more
excited to have as much
support in the industry as we have
and but i think also those those winds
blowing against us for years really
sharpened us up to be able to
be as skilled as we are today and so uh
it's it's fun to be in this industry
right now yep
that's great to play right on that point
so how did andy bittner get
excited about clean energy and abundance
what was the journey like that led you
to where you're at you know
originally i graduated with a broadcast
degree
from ohio university and
i wanted to tell the story of the
everyday person i wanted to be the one
that could
interpret that that mission that someone
had and be able to share that dream
in the broadcast world and the broadcast
world just didn't
connect with my heart as i got into it
and had a great internship in ohio
university as an
unbelievable journalism program as all
the bobcats out there know
and i found my way
with what i learned in that to
tell the story of the average person and
help them find sustainability and be
able to share their mission
and that happened through energy for me
and it was kind of a slow but steady
process
but i finally made it through and be
happy to kind of share with you
some some of the more details uh of how
it go
how it all got there but it was kind of
a
a winding road and a lot of rivers that
turned back and forth on each other
what was one of the core eureka moments
for you where you felt like
it was for sure
not only focusing on energy systems and
upgrading them around the planet
towards sustainability and abundance but
also that
you knew that there was a different
unique angle
on it which we'll explore as we talk
about guaranteed clean energy but it is
it's not your classic approach to this
it's
it's basically the most macro level most
pattern recognition
approach to how to best implement this
at
municipalities and schools yeah so
sustainability i think
is really what that eureka moment was
for me
and it actually happened a gentleman
came into my life i was on vacation
and i was currently at the time i owned
an led lighting company
because that was the most transformative
fastest payback
results in clean energy that existed
a decade ago and so i was right in the
thick of it
and to this day i think my grandmother
still believes that i invented the led
light bulb
and thank you grandma i love you um
the reality is that some amazing
scientists in the 1960s invented the led
light bulb and
and we were just there at the time when
it made the most financial sense to be
able to make the conversion and
let's play on this point for just a
moment because i think it's so
easy for people to understand this point
so
one of the components of transitioning
from older energy infrastructures to
newer
energy infrastructures is you look at
all these different variables that are
in
the equation and one of them is lighting
one of them is lighting
and it's a major system that
is part of a larger system as you look
at how
a building or a school district or a
municipality
uh consumes energy uh lighting and hvac
make up those two major systems and so i
was deeply entrenched in
in lighting for a large part of my early
career and got an
opportunity to understand how utility
bills functioned how
lighting as a system affected a utility
bill
and how lighting as a system also
affected all of the
other systems and we actually partnered
with hvac
companies across the country to
integrate
led because it was such a fast payback
measure it enabled cfos
and other fiscally conservative members
of
a company to be able to get behind
energy savings
measures rather than seeing them as just
a liability or just as a
an expensive asset that they had to
throw into their books
they were able to confirm this and
convert this
into real energy savings that they could
measure
and that was the perfect gateway drug
for me to start understanding
energy as a system and and fully develop
sustainability
and so i got to go back yes and can you
give us
a price example because i think this is
again a really cool relatable way to
explain this is that
the cfo is hearing andy bittner
pitch about led light upgrade to
this clean sustainable energy system
right and so the cfo gets this proposal
from you
that shows that this is how much you're
spending on the old
energy the old lighting infrastructure
right per month
and then you show by upgrading to the
led light infrastructure
you will spend this much less per month
and save this much more over you'll save
even after maybe a year
or two years you'll have saved all of
what you paid
or something like that yeah when we
started i mean the paybacks were
four or five years and those have
gradually now dropped to the two or
three year
return on investment so for most places
that's a no-brainer
that's an example of returning 30 per
year on your mutual funds
you do that in a heartbeat and so people
were
doing that in the led business and and
it made a lot of financial sense
but even though it was a no-brainer the
unique thing for
us as we were going through that process
was that people were still hesitant to
make the change because
it was their first time going through
that process
and even if somebody was delivering them
a ridiculous payback that upgraded
the environment of their buildings you
know made it cleaner and more efficient
and and you had a better work space
it was still new and so getting a chance
early on in my career to
understand how hard it was for people to
break through and try something
different in the energy space
even if they ultimately knew it was
going to work financially was
tremendous experience for where i sit
today as the ceo of this
advisory firm that's one of the biggest
breakthroughs in
in energy history and
it's so fun it's so fun to have started
and and seeing those challenges myself
personally as i was going through
manufacturing facilities and counting
lights and seeing the backbone of
america
through warehouses and manufacturing
facilities and places that had
dark corners where you had hundreds of
employees and
you'd leave those places not in a better
energy place but
we one time finished the factory and the
employees were crying
with happiness because they felt like
somebody cared about them because they
weren't working in the dark anymore
and so i i got a chance to feel what it
felt like to have
clean energy also make a change for a
person
and that experience was uh
incredibly empowering and energizing
for me and for our teams as as we
experienced that and
started to make little differences in
people's lives
beautiful so there's two
core things there that i feel are so
just
yummy the first one is that there's this
it's a very macro level view you like
view
the us to start so it will also be the
planet but you're viewing the us
and you call this like the backbone
there's all these warehouses there's all
these factories there's all these
buildings
that are that have hvac
that have lighting that have um
some energy infrastructures that look
like they're maybe
1970s 1980s based infrastructures right
they are and then and then there's all
this cool 2020 stuff
that exists yes and so um the game
is to be able to package together
the modern energy upgrades
in ways that are um
convenient affordable uh a no-brainer
for people to make the decision and
transition to and then you get all those
awesome stories of where like someone's
heart just begins gushing
and yeah and that's like well yeah in a
decade ago
led lighting was really one of the very
few things that had fast
that fast of a payback fast forward to
all the
innovation that we've had over the last
decade and and now you're talking about
upwards of seven or eight
measures in a building that can compete
or exceed the expectations of what led
lighting can do today
and what are those let's go so let's
talk about some of those right because
smart sensors i think is the general way
to
uh to talk about them as a whole and
looking at things as a system
so if you think about a building from
the 1970s which is often the type of
infrastructure
we're addressing and working with our
clients
as we specialize in working with school
districts and municipalities and so
these are buildings that were
built on low bid construction
a long time ago or even if they were
built last year they were built on low
bid construction so there's a lot of
opportunity
but ultimately the challenge has been
in the past these energy systems
were not treated as systems they were
treated as energy islands
and so lighting was a light bulb a
switch was a light switch
an hvac unit ran on or off
the fan was on or off uh
your insulation was just slapped in when
the building was
built uh and so there are a million
different
data points and focal points of an
energy building that we're
addressing and now all those things go
from being islands
to becoming connected systems cool
and so now a lighting system can talk to
the thermostat
and the thermostat can talk to the
sensors and you can see if there's
people in that hallway in the school
district or
if they're in that classroom or they're
not there
and then you start to add on just the
simple
smart systems that now can talk to each
other
and then you start adding on the layers
of how can you talk to
other data okay may i ask a quick
question so is this something like
the in 2020s
there's like a classroom and if the
classroom
at the school or in a municipality it's
like the conference room
let's see and that conference room
at uh 9 a.m
is going to have a meeting in it right
that
the air conditioning will only kick in
at like 8 45
a.m uh to cool the room right
um and then that kind of so this is like
what the smart
future looks like and so it's only for
when you know the humans are there
that the heating or the air conditioning
is gonna be tuned exactly as it needs to
be
based on like the calendar of the use of
the room
right stuff like this and to take it to
a next level
is now we can use predictive analytics
to track the weather
and so even though you're meeting maybe
at 8 45
if there's going to be a heat wave come
in at 8 45
you don't want to be pulling in outside
air at that time
it may be better to actually
heat it up an hour before okay and once
so
you're talking to all these other
systems that can dramatically
reduce the cost excellent and then
there's
also when we've been having other people
like jim williamson on the show we've
been talking about these nodal energy
markets and one of the other fascinating
things is literally if the school or
municipality
has generators on site or um
for storage yes generators
batteries capacitors capacitors yeah
okay cool for storage batteries
capacitors
and so when you have um batteries or
capacitors on site
sometimes you want to pull from the grid
or to pull from your clean energy
systems from your solar or
whatnot you want to um
pull at certain times or have uh
your because it's cheaper yes yeah
then at the peak times like for example
in la
you don't want to use your washing
machine
and dryer at noon because water is more
expensive
exactly and electricity is more
expensive yeah so it's the same
exact thing for businesses and
municipalities and school districts and
so one of the things that's happened
with our energy market
is that it's gotten smarter too and so
energy and electricity specifically
runs on a commodities market and that
commodities price fluctuates throughout
the day
and so you're literally talking about
timing when you're pulling your power
and communicating with the commodities
market now to
figure out should we be pulling a bunch
of power now
or later and you're able to graph and
see all that information
and so energy systems are now
molding heavily with data systems
and it's incredibly complex but it's
also
incredibly connected and simple once you
have the right architecture
and strategy in place and that's really
where our playground is
and in doing that we've able to been
able to
dramatically lower the cost of
installing these types of
infrastructures
uh for our clients and we're also doing
it at such massive scale
with the type of clients that we have
that we're able to drastically reduce
the cost of those
units as well too as we're doing across
the country i love that
so now let's take this from what
um guaranteed clean energy has been
doing so
um was this around 2013
when was the initial um
i think we launched officially
guaranteed clean energy
in 2015 or 2016. okay cool
cool so about six years or so
okay okay so six or so years ago
um so there's this process of
of both uh surveying
the um the
new clean energy technologies that exist
so you have to know which like there's
these seven core variables that we were
talking about
right and then there's all of the clean
energy technologies that like
fit into those variables right
to make the upgrades and then there's
the contractors
the contractors that are like
local in la or in the new york metro
area or in columbus
or miami or seattle or whatever wherever
the project is wherever the project
is and then so there's
yeah so there's all those clean energy
technologies
there's the contractors in the local
areas there's the schools and
municipalities that
sign on board to make these upgrades
right
and and then um
and then it's and then there's there's
this
um let's just go through this real quick
so the numbers
there's about over a hundred or so that
have been guaranteed clean energy has
helped
transition 100 or so schools and
municipalities right
okay so and this is across the u.s it's
across the u.s now
cool and so now this looks like
um we'll maybe take a general
uh case study as well and give an
example
but so the like it's like the
superintendent
uh or the board of the school area or
the municipality
right business manager whoever starts
the conversation with us
is coming and saying hey we're curious
about what would clean energy look like
on our campus
what's sustainability all about or just
flat out we have energy infrastructure
that we know we need to upgrade because
we're throwing money away
down the tube with our utility company
and
we need to find a better way of doing
things
and most of our clients are actually the
latter rather than the former
uh we love the clients who come to us
and say hey look we're trying to be
proactive in addressing these needs so
let's build a long-term strategy
that's embraced fully uh but
unfortunately the way that most of our
clients work and the reason that we
exist is to serve
people that are underserved and that's
why we work for schools and
municipalities
is that unfortunately they don't have
full-time energy engineering
staff and realistically it may not be a
great investment for a community anyway
because if you do
energy infrastructure properly you do it
in
large systems in projects that last
for a decade or longer so it makes sense
so what we do is we come in and serve
those clients specifically
to help them work with the average
budget
which is about a nickel uh is what they
have towards energy infrastructure but
their needs are in the millions
and so what we do is we help them find
the resources
and i think that that's probably the
first place that we got started
was helping people find the resources
and realize that the average school
district and municipality
actually has legislation that enables
them
to get energy infrastructure upgrade
funding
at extraordinarily low cost through
energy loan programs
through incentive programs through
rebates and so
that foundationally is where we start
and al and this is probably what's
closest to my heart is that we enable
people to
see the abundance that they already have
in their systems they've just not had
the time or the experience
of going through it every day like we do
and so we get an opportunity to share
that
as the advisor that comes in and helps
them build all of that
and i think that's probably the most
refreshing part for our clients is that
they realize oh my gosh we had no idea
there were millions of dollars
out there to help us address this if we
did it appropriately
and so that's really fun and you see a
lot of superintendents
relax and calm down because we're
talking about things that they want to
do
everyone wants to go sustainable and
everyone wants to to stop
throwing money down the toilet on their
utility bills but
they also understand that infrastructure
is not cheap and so
when we can come through and help them
find that money which is
75 of our initial goal uh
to help them find that strategically and
pay for ourselves and pay for the
project
yes then people really start to embrace
all the different changes that are out
there
because at the end of the day and i
think this is where we started so this
is a
we found our way back it's all about
being able to
be there for enhancing people enhancing
the planet
but ultimately especially in today's
society
you also have to address profit and so
there has to be a way to pay for this
there has to be a way to
conservatively show that this is working
yes
uh from a financial standpoint and so
that is what we call
sustainability and so that is the really
the founding principle of all the
changes that we make
for the people that were we're helping
and i think the fun part
for your your listeners is that
uh we're not doing this simply just
because we believe in the mission we do
wholeheartedly but it also at the end of
every project
leaves people in a better place than we
found them um
financially in their learning
environment and the planet in a better
place and
you know that's what makes it easy to be
a part of this company
every day when you wake up yep yep
yeah that plays um also deeply into our
uh ppp people planet profit that triple
bottom line life
that we'll be addressing also in
in more detail
so one of the big things like you
described is that the schools and
municipalities that want to come on
board
they're excited about this especially
about finding the money to be able to
make the transition this is the core
thing right and so there's a lot of tax
incentives that are
available to help schools and
municipalities make the transition
there are tons of incentives um so for
example our
headquarters is in columbus ohio and
in the state of ohio i think the list
right now is 38 different incentives
that we're able to tap into to help a
holistic school
and ohio is has headquarters of
many many many utility companies we're
probably one of the worst
places in the united states for clean
energy
and we still have 38 different incentive
programs
uh for clean energy and sustainability
come to
la and it's literally over a hundred i
mean there
there's so many different ways to be
able to help people and so we kind of
guide and and
navigate through those processes to help
people
find those and
if we can just do a brief um
ballpark so
a school or municipality that let's say
is doing a
one to ten million dollar um overhaul
on clean energy is that about yeah
that's about standard
okay one to ten million yeah okay
depending on size
it kind of spans that spectrum right
okay and then
um so then there's uh
so there's like there's the analysis of
the existing
uh energy infrastructure so they're sort
of um
like so there's the clean energy
advisors
like you guys and then there's um that
do this
like um think of us as
as the energy engineers yes that
work on behalf of the school yes we're
the energy
fiduciaries right we come in and it's
as though the school is our grandmother
right we're gonna do
the best that we possibly could for our
family and that's really the
responsibility of a fiduciary you come
in as the advisor
and you build this from the inside out
yes we're not product guys
we don't sell a product i'm not there to
sell somebody solar i'm not there to
sell somebody led light bulbs
um we know those industries really
really well
but our goal is to help someone
legitimately design for their facilities
because it's a whole lot different uh a
facility
in southern texas than northern texas
it's
totally different between northern texas
and
michigan yes and so we're gonna help
people find not
and not only navigate those different
incentives but also just how are their
systems going to operate differently and
and build that infrastructure from the
inside out
to where all those systems work together
the funding is there yes
the mechanisms are there and then the
little bow that we put on it
is that since we're doing all the
engineering
since we're doing all the calculations
and we're speccing and building
everything
it was really important for us for our
our customers to be able to trust
us and i think most of our customers are
going to trust us
initially because they can just
genuinely tell how much we care
about what it is that we're doing but
most importantly they don't need to
trust us because we've worked and built
a guaranteed savings insurance policy
to back every single bit of this work
and so
when we do work the school district or
municipality or any of our clients that
we're working with are taking
zero risk and having a hundred percent
opportunity of the up of the upside and
this must be the g
the guaranteed in the clean energy
that's the guaranteed and the clean
energy and i worked very hard to be able
to actually
say this say that because early in my
career uh
as a communicator working for businesses
never were you allowed to say guaranteed
right and so i fought back against that
and rebelled and said no i want
our systems in the future in the company
that that i'm the ceo of
to be able to build trust and guarantee
things
and be able to unequivocally have no
liability and guarantee that anything
that i touch
is going to be better than i found it
yes and i think that that's a real
mission of sustainability too and
and that's inherent within the system
of what we're practicing and preaching
uh
internally and externally and i think
that that that sustainable mission is
is a fun one and and that's what really
gets into the abundant nature of
our of our role and uh and why i get to
smile every once in a while at work
yes and i love how you talk about it
as serving a family member which is a
perfect way to view it the more that
we view our uh interactions with humans
on the planet
as uh perpetually dealing with our
family
right um the more tight-knit we can make
our species
i grew up in a town of 900 people and so
westfield center is not just my hometown
it is my family i was raised by a
community
and so i felt the benefits of that
uh if my parents didn't catch me and
align me then the neighbors did and
if they didn't then their friends did
and so i had a lot of people rooting for
me
but also helping me keep the path
and then when you win you also get to
celebrate as a community
and so we want to be able to provide
those same
opportunities and and build that sense
of community
through energy projects because
communities are clamoring for them now
when they should be
and i think a lot of communities are
clamoring for them now because
they're starting to realize the abundant
nature of them
and that it really just comes down to do
you have a plan or don't you have a plan
and those with a plan are yeah reaping
the rewards
right now yeah that's great there's a
there's a lot of excitement around both
um individuals
having future authoring around their own
life and actualization right as well as
cities municipalities
schools collectives right having
these plans around their actualization
and the fullest potential
so let's revisit this uh example in
as much detail as you feel is um
appropriate
so
so we were we were giving an example of
a
potential school or municipality in in
texas or michigan
right this is of course this is the
simple difference in especially
temperature
right is the right thing like obviously
in the northern part of the u.s you're
gonna have to heat the school or
municipality
precisely a lot um because it's gonna be
cold
really cold um but
in um in the south you're gonna have to
cool uh because it's gonna be
really hot right and so so now you see
there's these
unique um differences across the us but
then
let's play on the idea because
regardless in michigan or texas
regardless there's going to be
a uh 1 to 10 million dollar cost
in upgrading to the clean energy okay
certainly there'll be infrastructure
cost
costs to make the upgrades so now
let's say out of um
in this process of being like family and
helping them
in the journey um
we kind of went through the process of
there this there's this old there are
these old infrastructures and there's
like the analysis of the old
infrastructures
there's the analysis of how much they're
paying per month or per year for the old
infrastructures
right there's the analysis of which new
technologies
replace the old ones there's the
analysis of which contractors come in to
do the replacing
right um there's the analysis of how to
get
the funding from the tax incentives and
whatnot that are
different per state but also similar at
the federal
level and the bid processes that we go
through everything
is different from state to state but
realistically what you're describing is
that there is a large
strategy that needs to be worked out and
not only is it strategy but it's also
operational
and and you have to go from start to
finish
and i think one of the things that
really kind of launched our firm on a
national scale
and one of the reasons that we recently
are coming out as the top clean tech
company according to startup magazine
is because we've been able to streamline
the process
of what used to take cities and
municipalities
three to four years to put together
these strategies we can execute that
entire operational
process get them funding install and
build the whole thing and get it
launched
within a six-month time frame okay so
within even
six months you
wow that's crazy so within six months
and all the new infrastructures will be
in place
the that's when you're gonna start the
install okay that's when you start the
install yeah okay so there's like six
that's a cherry picked
time frame right so six more months for
install on top of that ish
depending on the size of the of
already really epic that you can go from
start to almost
end of process within including all the
energy upgrades within
a year with the scope at which we're
working
three to four years would be reasonable
most people if they're being honest
to accomplish 15 plus energy measures
as well as the depth of of engineering
and studies and implementation maybe six
years
so in a playful way we may even be able
to take it from six years to six months
yeah and that's that's gigantic but
uh i think the other really breakthrough
thing
that uh kind of set us apart and and
that also helps that process speed up
is that people are having to wonder will
this pay for itself
when will it pay back taking the
liability off the table for the district
i think is a big part of why people are
willing to
move forward this it's guaranteed and
our guarantee is backed by
the two most conservative financial
institutions in the country
insurance companies and banks
and so those are the guys that are
ultimately underwriting these processes
because we've been able to prove time
and time and time again that these are
great investments for communities
and so they're willing to take the risk
so the community doesn't have to and so
that completely takes it off the table
uh and so
when it comes to the risk side it it's
completely taken off the table but then
when it comes to the
internal victory side and i think this
is one of the reasons why i'm really
excited to be on your show and and
communicate this is
for the last decade in clean energy
people have been asking me andy when
is clean energy when should i do it when
should i put solar onto our school
when should we do this when can we start
putting this on my manufacturing
facility and i think that
big breakthrough moment that we've
achieved as a society
is that clean energy is now
cheaper than the grid
and that is something that feels so good
for me to be able to share from my heart
because we've been waiting for this
moment it's literally cheaper
to power a school district with clean
energy than it is to
do it with fossil fuels and and that is
just
uh what a feeling to be able to do that
and and
i think as a whole our economy will get
there i think as a whole other firms
will be able to communicate that
and the rising tide will flow to all the
ships but right now we're one of the
very few companies
that can literally say that with a
straight face to their clients
because of the holistic nature that we
put together the projects and because
we're not selling them solar panels and
because we don't have
giant overhead and we don't have giant
contractor fees
uh you know the average person who does
what we do
uh in one section
just project managing and being a
general contractor charges 30 percent
and we charge 10 to 13 and do
five or six other things including
bringing the money
and so yeah we've been able to use a lot
of the efficiencies
of uh just running a business better
and more efficient and more streamlined
and more scalable
in ways that have also been able to
drastically reduce those costs for our
clients that's great
so it's a very fun point to be able to
say to somebody clean energy is cheaper
than the grid
and i guarantee it yeah wow what a what
a tremendous
thing and obviously we stand on the
shoulders of giants when we say that yes
guys like tesla guys like um
the victor schauberger
and um what let's i mean edison
and and all the guys that were building
everything and walter russell
um guys that i i've studied deeply
deeply to
to help understand the principles of
abundance and sustainability and clean
energy
so we're here as a society now and so
now we get to
uh join the party yeah
i love the the humility
of constantly you know standing on the
shoulders of giants i love that i love
how
agile the startup mentality is with you
guys in being able to navigate this and
make everything efficient
i love how there's this
big announcement in a sense that clean
energy so the synthesis
of wind and solar biofuels
hydro all of that is cheaper than
the fossil fuel that we've been using
from the grid for the last decades it's
unbelievable so it's now like 2021 is
like tipping point
and it's guaranteed which is another
fascinating component so you can use
insurance companies and banks with
because you have a proven track record
now right
where they basically say that okay
school slash municipality
by making this transition to clean
energy infrastructures within five
or 10 years you will have completely
paid off
what you paid to make the clean energy
upgrade and you will be earning
we can structure in a lot of different
ways for a lot of different school
districts or munis they're getting those
benefits day one so they don't even have
to wait to make
uh the return on investment because
we're accessing incentives
that aren't coming from their pocket oh
yeah that's interesting that's right so
you can access the
millions of dollars that are available
in incentives
right to pay for it to make it so that
it's
not structured anywhere near like a home
mortgage
is so yeah a home mortgage people are
very
aware of that you're taking a 30-year
period to pay back twice the amount of
the
of the cost of the property that you
purchased
right but for this energy upgrade it's
like
you can take all these incentives and
pay for
50 of it up front or something right
like that
the mortgage is a reasonable analogy
except
let's let's take it to what it actually
is imagine if you could get a mortgage
and reduce your payment for living by 30
and that's the epic thing that that
happens when you're
combining energy efficiency and dropping
your utility bills by 30 percent
now you're getting long-term ownership
where before you were renting
or simply throwing your money down the
utilities coffers
interesting and then you pay the extra
so all of the the 30
that you're saving in energy savings
you're then
basically paying off the uh clean energy
switch
right um and then some and then some but
you know imagine you you are that school
district and
and you receive 10 million dollars in
upgrades
you receive 10 million dollars in
upgrades today and so you walk into your
bill
your buildings uh in the fall
and your kids go oh my gosh we have a
brand new school how did we pay for all
this and you go
oh well all we did was we just took the
money that we were throwing down
the toilet at the utility company and we
worked with an advisor to leverage that
and turn it into an asset
and that's simply all that we're doing
is we're just teaching people how to
treat energy
like an asset that works for you rather
than against you
and that's one of the main principles
that we've been able to build on
and really where the future of our
company is going
because we started doing this
with municipalities in school districts
with the intent of being able to
have clean energy and abundance and
sustainability embraced
by communities but ultimately we wanted
to have that same type of
uh excitement and accessibility be able
to get there to the individual
and we thought that what we were going
to have to do
was drive down the cost of these
renewables
by doing so many on a large scale for
large entities like school districts and
municipalities that we could drive the
cost down to be able to do it at your
house
and make it affordable there and what we
found is actually while we were building
this there were a
whole bunch of really smart people
across the world building blockchain
technologies
perfect and where we've been able to
combine uh where we thought we were
headed and take a
giant leap is that now
we're launching a new way of doing this
because there's probably a few of your
listeners who when i said
uh we were leveraging banks and
insurance companies
as excited as they probably were that
that the
giant institutions were now backing
sustainability
there's probably a little bit of them
that also said well but
it would be even better if it wasn't
you could leap frog even if you could
leapfrog even that and have
decentralized
ownership and fractional ownership of
these renewables
uh to the individual level yes and so
that's another big part of what we're
launching
uh and we've got to sign up on uh
win win win earth so this is our
shameless plug but what we've done is
we've found a way to decentralize that
ownership of these renewables and
from day one get the individual person
involved in
owning these renewables and taking the
tax
incentives for investing in renewables
that we're doing on these entities that
are non-taxable
so when we build a renewables plan at a
school district
the school district can't actually take
the tax incentives
and so what we want to be able to do now
and what we are doing
is opening up that ownership to the
individual level to where
someone can take the
dollars that they're already spending
and it's very unique the way that we're
doing this
it's leveraging in the same way that a
school district
is uh spending too much on their utility
bills
and so when you put in a new system that
drops it by thirty percent
you're just taking and leveraging that
money that used to go over here down the
toilet and turning it into an asset
we're doing the same exact principle for
the individual people
the money that the average person makes
and this was really important for us
which was
how do we take the tax incentive game
that wall street plays
and bring it to main street yep and so
what we did was
we we modeled this and said okay
blockchain exists what if we use the
blockchain as a way to
track on a trusted ledger transparently
the ownership of these renewables
prove that that fractional ownership of
that solar array
on your local school district is bought
and paid for by the
by this person and so that person then
can yield the tax incentives that come
from that
and so the way that this works from a
simple
standpoint and i'm probably making it
sound way too complicated but
i'm getting to a point here where the
average american makes 64 000
a year their federal income tax is 10
000 on that in 2020.
the average american has to take that 10
000
and give that to the government they
don't get any say
in how that money spent or done that's
uh one of the things that you do is you
pay your taxes and that's why we have
all these talks about you know the rich
are getting are paying no
taxes but main street is paying all the
taxes
and it's true and we wanted to fix that
but we wanted to fix it not by screaming
and yelling but by doing something about
it
and the screaming yelling helped but now
we have a real plan for it
and so what we can do is you can
literally turn
in a form it's called a w-4 and it's
your tax withholdings and so if you're a
person making sixty four thousand
dollars a year
you're paid ten thousand dollars in tax
benefits it
the easiest way to get tax incentives is
to check a box and say you have a child
so if you have a child under 17 it's two
thousand dollars per kit
okay i only have one kid he's amazing uh
shout out to my son and wife who are my
light and love
but now you've got two thousand dollars
deducted now there's eight thousand
dollars left
what we've done is simplified this so
easy to where you can take that eight
thousand dollars
and instead of flushing that essentially
down the toilet from an asset
standpoint for you personally you can
take that same eight thousand dollars
and invest that into a renewables plant
for a community for a school for a
municipality near you
or across the world it doesn't matter
and for every dollar that you put in
you get a dollar and 10 cents back year
one
in tax incentives so if you put in eight
thousand dollars you're gonna get eight
thousand
eight hundred dollars back in tax
incentives
so literally the same money
that would come into your paycheck
is the exactly the same amount of money
that would still come into your paycheck
the difference is that the money that
you donated to the federal government
you now get to donate to a building a
renewables plant at your school
and you win too because you get an
additional 10 back
and the real kicker is that now you
fractionally own a percentage of that
renewables power plant
so every time that the sun comes out on
that solar array
it's generating you income and this is
the secret
that the wealthy are using is they're
using tax incentives
to create long-term assets and
we're doing the same thing now for main
street where
that person can every single year
create this long-term income stream and
by the way these are 20-year assets
so you're buying into a 20-year solar
array or a 20-year wind array
or wind farm that is going to pay you
out every month
a little bit of money and to me that is
just
the coolest thing that is possible and
we're thankful to
the blockchain for being able to build a
use case around that
uh and be able to use that uh because
it's just perfect timing for us to be
able to skip all the middlemen and go
straight to
being able to have people that care
about this
be able to take the funds that they're
already
spending and that's that's pivotal to me
too
you don't have to come out of your
pocket any new money it's all
existing what you're already doing you
just now have the ability to redirect
those funds
to something that you're passionate
about something that you care about
and in the true sustainability people
plan it
profit way it's a win-win-win for
everybody too it's a win for that school
district
it's a win for you and ultimately it's
also good for
the united states government too there's
a reason those tax incentives exist
we need a better grid we're pouring
hundreds of millions and
trillions of dollars possibly into the
grid because it it needs it
this is the best way to make that
investment and
you can do it on an individual level
which is just
uh extremely amazing now
yes wow
yes
okay okay okay
do you want to move the car
should we finish this we can wrap the
show we're pretty much that was
beautiful
that was so beautiful yeah we we just
have to make a um
the movement of one of the vehicles
outside um
given given there is construction
happening on the property welcome
to l.a well welcome to yeah say thanks
for entering our world for a moment uh
their viewers
so that was really eloquently described
so that was uh let's let's give some
action items though as
as we wrap um yeah
unless you feel like you want to move
and then come
you want to move the whip uh and come
back no i think it feels pretty good it
feels this is a great way to i think so
too
cool to cap this i think so too um
because
it's like being able to take um like you
said
what already has been happening on the
uh wall street um
tax incentives right um and then
bringing that
to main street bringing that into
the hearts of our families and enabling
them to create
uh long-term um
uh wealth generation right with
fractional ownership
of clean energy infrastructures that
benefits the school and municipalities
in their local areas
and they're using the tax dollars that
they're already spending anyway they're
getting sovereignty
over where they can allocate their tax
dollars which is something that people
have been talking about for decades is
how do i direct the money
that i'm giving the government into the
places that i want to see it spent
right and that's really what also puts
sovereignty
into the people which is what
initially the founding fathers were
trying to do um
and so now there's been a huge
disconnect with the
massive increase in population of the uh
united states right which then has
created this
uh uh well and people and communities
are different
with the amount of people in congress
that are now representing such
uh a bear a small increase in people in
congress
and a massive increase in the population
of the country is what created that
massive
imbalance and so now yeah gaining
sovereignty gaining long-term wealth
generation
yeah it's great do you want to
decentralize nature right we're
we're having the discussion i think as a
society across the world right now about
the power of decentralizing
these different places and letting local
economies and letting local people
be able to make decisions for themselves
and
it's a huge opportunity to go back and
change these things and so fractional
ownership
of renewables is a big play but
being able to have communities i mean
when we finish a project
that community that school district has
power on site
so a hurricane comes you know a giant
storm
it doesn't matter what it is the power
grid can get knocked out and that school
is a community center it has power if a
community needs to get together
you've got your own way of of producing
power
and so we're going to just continue to
build on those things because on top of
that
once you can produce power now it opens
up to
one of our other projects which is
opening up vertical farming on site
at school districts and municipalities
so that you can have
local healthy food and now you can start
to build in
uh different ways to get the
youth as they go through the process
not only learning about sustainability
but also ingrained
in workforce development and learning
how to
build a sustainable economy right there
because it exists there
it's not magically learn a bunch of
stuff in this textbook and then go off
into the world
it's all happening right there on the
campus and everybody sees it
and experiences it for the 12 years that
they're in high school
that they're in in their education
system in their community
and i think that that will make profound
impacts over a long term
yes time frame yeah one of the big
things
um as you were uh sharing i was pulling
up all these great images and i was
thinking about the young people that
were walking in
like myself back uh you know 10 plus
years ago
walking in into this clean energy
upgraded school or municipality and just
feeling my heart
uh feel so much more cared for
and being able to actualize my fullest
potential and so that's the type of
emotion that we hope to move
people with and also the
the fractional ownership one andy's got
a lot of other big plans for you know
energy infrastructure upgrades are like
you were saying they're the first big
module
the fundamental module and then there's
all of the additional modules that
come immediately after that they do yeah
yeah and that support is is so huge
though so that
you need us to move the car right yeah
cool all right cool
we're we're about to um i'm closing the
show right now
like two minutes is it cool okay um
so yeah so that's beautiful and there's
by the way so the the links uh in the
bio
uh are for guaranteed clean energy
so if you guys have a um
any school municipality connections that
you feel like are excited or interested
about getting on board
go to guarantycleanenergy.com that links
in the bio below
also the link to win win win earth is in
the bio below so get signed up for the
fractional ownership
um and also um get other people excited
about this this
is the decentralized movement this is
the future right um
and you can also access the link to um
andy's
linkedin profile you can go and connect
with him there and then send him message
there as well so those are the ways to
connect
um beautiful show my brother thank you
great to be here this was awesome really
appreciate such a pleasure yeah
and really appreciate the viewer support
you know we're we're building that wait
list on
win win win earth and that once that
hits a critical maximum we can
literally go and deploy hundreds of
millions of projects
that exist out there and uh we want
those to go to the people rather than to
centralized networks so yeah we're
pretty passionate about it and we're
excited to see it happen
you're my definitely my big brother in
the space i love you so much
good stuff thank you this is beautiful
this is so beautiful
get on board everyone get on board we
love you thank you for tuning in
and hit those links in the bio below
check it out get involved
and also subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet also leave
us a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we'd love to hear from you
like the video share the video with
other people that you feel like this
would make a profound impact on
infinite love thank you so much for
tuning in and
we will see you soon bye everyone
peace goodbye everyone